selon le radar l'hélicoptère que nous
devons intercepter et proches mais au
mieux du ciel on a bien du mal à le
repérer et justement
on va voir encore un signe
il est beaucoup plus long que nous en un
clin d'oeil nous l'avons rattrapé nous
entrons en contact radio avec lui nous
devons vite comprendre ces intentions si
les perdus nous devons le guider à bon
port s'il est hostiles nous pourrions la
battre évidemment en dernier recours
il voulait sortir des plateaux prendre
l'air tâter le terrain
ils ne vont pas être déçus
Carole Rousseau et Benjamin Castaldi
partent à la rencontre d'hommes et de
femmes ordinaires au métier
extraordinaire
[Musique]
Salon de Provence c'est la base de la
Patrouille de France c'est aussi
l'Académie de l'armée de l'air française
à 50 km au nord de Marseille
immersion immédiate dans une école
d'élite
chaque année 200 jeunes officiers
prennent leur envol ici à salon ils sont
formés à tous les métiers de l'aviation
ingénieurs officier mécanicien et pour
certains pilotes
discipline et adrénaline c'est le
quotidien de ces jeunes officiers ce
sera aussi le nôtre pendant trois jours
Carole va braver sa peur de vide dans un
avion sans moteur
Benjamin va s'initier aux techniques des
commandos
c'est parti nous prendrons nos premiers
cours de pilotage dans un simulateur
ou à bord d'un Mirage 2000
nous apprendrons à survivre dans tous
les milieux hostiles
ensemble nous allons découvrir les
coulisses de cette école d'exception
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pendant que Carole prépare sa valise mon
aventure commence dans un hôpital
militaire de la région parisienne
il paraît que je vais peut-être avoir la
chance de voler en Mirage 2000 mais
avant cela il faut passer une visite
médicale assez assez complète pour pour
voir si je suis apte ou non à voler sur
cet appareil on croise les doigts
voler en avion de chasse c'est mon rêve
mais pour avoir cette chance il faut une
forme physique parfaite le résultat de
la visite sera sans appel
on va passer au bon de mesure pour
vérifier si vous êtes éjectable ou pas
éjectable ou pas
en télé généralement on est éjectable
et oui en cas de pépin un pilote doit
pouvoir s'éjecter de son appareil à tout
moment et ça ce n'est pas permis à tout
le monde
rassembler ensemble vos genoux
sont trop longues étant donné que vous
êtes juste au ras du cockpit en cas
d'éjection vous perdez les jambes il est
pas forcément ce qu'on recherche
ça peut servir pour être éjectable il
faut pas que votre tête dépasse le
maître donc on est plutôt bien
que votre fémur dépasse les 65 cm et
votre tibia les 60 cm voilà il y a un
vrai gabarit pilote vous êtes éjectable
bon en cas de panne je pourrais
m’éjecter de l'avion mais à vrai dire je
n'ai aucune envie de sauter en plein vol
deuxième épreuve ouais je sais on dirait
Frankenstein on va regarder dans mon
cerveau
mon certificat d'aptitude de déport du
résultat de cet examen puisque j'ai eu
un accident de moto il y a quelques
années et que j'ai perdu connaissance
donc
l'armée de l'air ne prendra aucun risque
moi non plus
donc je fais un peu quand même
à l'aide de ces flashs le médecin veut
savoir si je risque une crise
d'épilepsie en plein vol
pour moi c'est fini
un quart d'heure plus tard voilà c'est
bon c'est marqué là je suis apte pour
voler sur Mirage 2000
notre immersion à l'école de l'air
commence avec l'aube sur la place
d'Armes de la base chaque lundi la
cérémonie du drapeau ouvre la semaine
des élèves
lorsque le colonel arrivera
effectivement on se tiendra de manière
immobile sortira les mains des poches
tout est calibré
le colonel le voici c'est le numéro 3 de
l'école il passe en revue chaque
promotion d'élèves chaque geste est
millimétré
envoyer
le mistral nous met à dire épreuve
[Musique]
Salon-de-Provence accueille 450 élèves
ils ont entre 20 et 26 ans
et parmi eux il y a une centaine de
femmes ici ces futurs officiers font
leur classe de soldats après le
commandement et les arts de la guerre
[Musique]
dans quelques années il commanderont les
troupes de l'Armée de l'Air opérations
extérieure mission de paix protection de
notre territoire il risqueront leur vie
surtout les fronts
en attendant moi j'ai envie de bouger
[Musique]
dans les sous-sols je me mets dans la
peau d'un élève
je laisse ici mes vêtements civils je
m'attendais à uniforme bleu marine mais
c'est du kaki qu'on donne et je vais le
comprendre pourquoi
très bien
comme ça
un petit selfie
les choses sérieuses commencent je
rejoins ma classe des premières années
qui ont attiré à salon il y a trois mois
tout juste
bienvenue à l'école de l'air et leur
premier cours commence aujourd'hui
l'adjudant yves est un ancien commando
parachutiste il a fait le Tchad Djibouti
le Sénégal et l'ex-Yougoslavie dans un
premier temps on va faire un petit
échauffement rustique et après vous
allez voir vous allez voir c'est la
petite surprise d'accord j'ai compris
c'est-à-dire
moi allez ensuite allez
c'est d'abord
on suit
ce type est diabolique j'en peux plus
mais les élèves sont derrière moi comme
un seul homme je tiens bon
allez les gars allez c'est parti
pour ne pas s'écrouler il faut faire
confiance à ses camarades ici on appelle
ça l'esprit de cohésion une heure qu'on
s'échauffe il y a déjà de la casse allez
allez allez allez on
voilà c'est bien
j'ignorais qu'avant d'apprendre à voler
il fallait savoir ramper ça s'appelle
une remise à niveau je ne regrette pas
d'être venu
et ben
c'est quand même un truc de jeune à rien
mon pauvre Benjamin pendant que tu
transpires avec tes travaux pratiques
moi j'ai théorie
salon est aussi une école d'ingénieur
car l'aviation est une arme de haute
technologie alors les lunettes ici que
l'on soit pilote ou mécanicien on est
scientifique avant tout après un cours
d'aérodynamique j'ai droit à une petite
leçon de mécanique le professeur va nous
expliquer les limites de résistance
d'une aile en cas de manœuvre extrême
je veux plus prendre l'avion c'est ça
tout à fait alors si on regarde ce qui
peut se passer quand on va trop loin ça
peut être vraiment catastrophique il y a
pas moyen de s'en sortir
des ailes c'est inévitable et il y a pas
moyen de s'en sortir
et pour bien comprendre c'est incident
ici on fait les choses grandeur nature
les élèves tords une vraie à l'aide de
cette machine
les futurs ingénieurs calculent la
résistance de la structure
j'espère qu'ils vont bien retenir cette
leçon demain des vies humaines
dépendront de
[Musique]
moi j'ai fini mon entraînement
coquille protège-tibia gants maintenant
on va commencer à se battre et on va pas
faire dans la dentelle
ok non on garde allez top
voilà voilà
c'est quoi c'est cool allez allez
reviens on en apprend des choses à salon
même à se débarrasser d'un étrangleur et
là il vous a pris vous avez les
coquilles moi j'aime bien elle est
partie génitales rotation du bassin là
je reviens je tape et après avant de
partir boum un deuxième petit coup qui
fait le plus peu le moins d'accord un
coup de poing un tranchant pomme on
pense pas que tes pilotes ou ceux qui se
dessinaient des pilote ou même navigant
c'est pas vrai
ils vont partir en opération extérieure
et il faut des missions opérationnelles
ils sont sur des territoires plus ou
moins hostiles et s'il y a une éjection
qui doit se faire s'il tombe sur un
ennemi il faut qu'il sache le l'attaquer
le neutraliser le détruire en jargon
militaire détruire ça veut dire tuer et
ici on apprend à le faire à mains nues
dans ce groupe je ne vois qu'une fille
et elle m'impressionne
[Musique]
depuis le début elle enchaîne comme nous
tous elle rend coup pour coup à ses
collègues hommes
voilà ok c'est bon
à mon tour de passer à la pratique je
vais découvrir les plaisirs du vol libre
aucun élève n'y échappe même ceux qui ne
seront pas pilotes pendant leur
scolarité ils doivent cumuler senteurs
de planeur toutes les bases du pilotage
sont là
en apprenant à jouer avec les courants
ascendants on peut rester des heures en
vol oui mais c'est pas un avion avec des
moteurs et c'est pas un avion avec des
hélices
il est très très rassurant mon
instructeur de vol
mais avant le décollage je dois quitter
mes vêtements civils
de vol
je te remets
je me transforme on élève pilote mon nom
l'escadron
aujourd'hui nous allons voler à deux
planeurs le mien est celui du
sous-lieutenant Sébastien qui vient
prendre son cours la présence doit pas
vous stresser
vous faites comme si je n'étais pas là
toute façon moi j'aurais peut-être
tourné de l'oeil d'ici là donc
Sébastien vole en planeur depuis deux
ans mais moi c'est mon baptême j'espère
juste ne pas être malade oui je crois
que
si vous voulez en prendre quelques-uns
pour mettre dans les poches il faut
toujours voler le ventre plein faut pas
étendre l'hypoglycémie
et après j'arrête
bon maintenant il est temps de voir à
quoi ressemble un planeur
j'avoue que je n'imaginais pas ça aussi
exigu
es
voilà je pensais que c'était plus gros
que ça quand même
moi ça me ferait plutôt penser à un
bobsleigh avec des ailes
je peux je peux rentrer dedans pour voir
si je rentre dedans
si il se passe un problème je vais vous
demander d'évacuer le panneur donc ça
sera un ordre très clair on évacue en
évacue on évacue trois fois on saute on
saute on saute
et voilà alors
vous me tenez la main quand même
[Rires]
le système automatique d'ouverture reste
accroché à la sangle et à mesure que
vous souhaitez ça va dérouler et ça va
ouvrir le parachute
il ne manquerait plus qu'il me demande
de sauter dans le vide
l'élève lui ne veut pas devenir pilote
de chasse son rêve c'est l'hélicoptère
mais en attendant il doit faire ses
classes sur un planeur avant chaque vol
il vérifie sa machine les aérosins le
parachute les ailes tout doit être
parfait
et pour le sortir du hangar on pousse à
la main
350 kg pour 20 mètres d'envergure je
vais voler sur une plume
pour décoller il faut marcher jusqu'au
bout de la piste j'en profite pour faire
connaissance avec mon instructeur vous
êtes déjà fait très très peur
dans un champ d'Afrique du Sud
et la nuit venant effectivement là
c'était plus le stress du haut vol mais
c'était le stress
ici le danger ce ne sont pas les lions
c'est le mistral tout aussi féroce
bon vous avez le numéro de mon mari
dites à mes enfants que je les aime à
lui aussi
enfin je suis entre de bonnes mains
allez
mon pilote est un trou du vol à voile il
collectionne les médailles il est même
vice-champion d'Europe
ça devrait aller
pour décoller le planeur et tracté par
un avion
l'accélération est très douce avant même
de m'en rendre compte nous ne touchons
plus le sol
ici pas de hublot mais une grande
verrière l'union avec les éléments est
saisissante
je ne suis pas vraiment dans mon élément
mais le cordon ombilical qui me relie
encore à l'avion me rassure
c'est très agréable
pendant que tu planes moi je suis
toujours cloué au sol et je vais prendre
une sonde survie car quand un pilote
s'éjectent il n'a pas grand chose sur
lui vous allez vous retrouver seul face
à la nature et vous n'aurez que ce que
vous avez dans votre paquetage et dans
votre tête pour pouvoir
approfondir la situation et durée dans
le temps jusqu'à ce que les cours
arrivent
le voici le paquetage du pilote intégré
au cgjectable il est aussi expulsé de
l'avion
cette partie part bien sûr et rester
branché sous les fesses du pilote
à l'intérieur qu'est-ce qui va y trouver
dedans le strict nécessaire pour tenir
24 heures allumettes au nourriture
couverture thermique et même un
accessoire surprise
des lunettes qui permettent d'être
protégés du soleil et quand on est en
montagne et ben on est bien contents
mais l'exercice a lieu dans les bois le
scénario et ce qu'il y a de plus simple
votre avion a eu un problème technique
vous avez dû vous éjecter
d'abord il faut construire un abri et se
débrouiller avec les moyens du bord
cette cordelette par exemple elle vient
de mon parachute
maintenant on creuse un trou pour
abriter le feu et ce n'est pas une masse
à faire oui je sais au cinéma ça va plus
vite
ça m'a bien fatigué il ne reste plus
qu'à allumer le feu
ah ça y est
maintenant que nous sommes installés
[Musique]
ah non Benjamin désolé je ne peux rien
pour toi
l'élève est prêt nous avons atteint
l'altitude de largage 1200 mètres
on a instinctivement le réflexe de
couper sa respiration quand même hein
un peu plus quand même
pas le temps d'être malade la formation
de l'élève commence au programme des
virages très serrés
je te propose qu'on commence le premier
exercice
alors on va prendre un peu de vitesse
et on va passer à côté de
[Musique]
voilà
et voilà ça va ouais on va revenir à
côté de lui tout tranquillement par la
gauche
[Musique]
je crois plutôt que ma séance de torture
ne fait que commencer
[Musique]
je suis une espèce de sensation
totalement bizarre
ce n'est plus un baptême de l'air c'est
un cours de voltige qui n'en finit pas
voilà on contracte encore on souffle
et voilà c'est fini pour les grosses
manœuvres ça va
je pense que j'ai perdu au moins trois
kilos là
une demi-heure dans le ce cockpit me
suffit j'ai hâte d'être au sol ça tombe
bien le cours est fini l'élève se pose
[Musique]
il a fait tout bien s'il fallait faire
c'est maintenant un autre tour
d'atterrir
tout simplement
on se pose à 90 km heure
nous voilà enfin au sol je suis soulagée
[Musique]
que ça
on a eu de la chance
et voilà et merci Beaucoup de rien
l'élève lui a l'air plus à l'aise
en forme que moi comment ça s'est passé
ça va c'était un peu un peu turbulent au
départ là
déjà à très bien et comment vous êtes
vous quand vous faites les petits trucs
comme ça là les petits virages et tout
parce que moi j'étais pas bien du tout
métier
alors ça y est elle a volé ça s'est bien
passé ça s'est très bien passé
si c'est c'est génial les conditions
optimales quand tu es là-haut ça bouge
pas c'est nickel tu as l'impression
d'être une feuille après il m'a fait
faire deux trois petits virages un peu
violent quand même j'ai trouvé pour pour
mon goût à moi-même et j'ai eu un peu
peur déjà ça s'est bien passé j'ai fait
du feu j'ai monté ma tante de survie et
j'ai pété un fumigène parce que j'étais
en détresse
non pas justement pas du tout
fin de notre première journée avec un
peu de chance les prochains jours seront
moins éprouvants
[Musique]
allez arrête-toi à droite un peu plus
nickel
[Applaudissements]
notre immersion à l'école de l'air
continue il est 8h et la base tourne
déjà à plein régime
[Musique]
ces filles et ces garçons ont à peine
plus de 20 ans avant de devenir officier
ils doivent s'aguer se transformer en
véritable soldat être prêt à donner leur
vie ensuite ils seront pilotes de chasse
d'hélicoptère d'autres deviendront
mécaniciens ou contrôleur aérien il
participeront à des missions de guerre à
des opérations dans les coins chauds de
la planète et ils veilleront sur notre
espace aérien
cette deuxième journée nous allons la
passer ensemble en se serrant les coudes
ça devrait être moins difficile surtout
qu'on commence par un parcours aquatique
dans l'Atlantique
c'est ça quand un pilote tombe à la mer
il doit avant tout s'extraire de son
harnais de parachute et ce n'est pas
facile il faut libérer les deux jambes
la ceinture et les bras et tout ça dans
l'eau
se retrouvez piégé dans la toile du
parachute sinon c'est la noyade assurer
mais ici heureusement pas de voilure ce
n'est qu'un entraînement
pourquoi j'ai le cœur qui bat c'est les
jambes le plus compliqué
la trouille
dans les airs je suis pas à l'aise dans
l'eau donc il y a un moment c'est bon
quoi allez on y va
donc là on dit que j'ai sauté
[Musique]
j'ai du mal à me débarrasser de mon
harnais dans la vraie vie je serai sans
doute en train de me noyer
[Rires]
super dur c'est pas gagné
j'ai assez lourd avec le poids de l'eau
ça alourdit encore
alors vous imaginez la voile derrière
ouais on peut vite paniquer enfin bon
je voudrais bien tester le plongeoir des
trois mètres
Benjamin quand même
t'inquiète pas Carole tout va bien enfin
c'est quand même un peu haut
allez moi aussi j'y retourne
tu peux même sauter en parachute dans
l'Atlantique maintenant oui enfin
restons modeste ça reste une piscine
[Musique]
c'est vrai que là on a des conditions
optimales
[Musique]
d'Atlantique dans une eau à 12 degrés
et qui vont faire tout ça ouais quand
même ça me paraît un peu dispensable
dans l'eau à 12 degrés les chances de
survie sont minces en un peu plus d'une
heure on est inconscient au-delà de deux
heures on est mort
ce parcours aquatique nous a ouvert
l'appétit ça tombe bien nous avons
rendez-vous avec le patron de l'école le
général Paulet
il nous invite à déjeuner dans sa salle
à manger personnelle
pas de doute ici c'est bien
l'aristocratie militaire qui nous reçoit
un autre table un couple Anne-Laure et
Anthony ils sont mariés ils sont aussi
pilotes de chasse tous les deux lui sur
mes rage de mille elle son Mirage F1
[Musique]
je vous en parle moi je vous en faire
forcément la grande
publicités
en France Anne-Laure a été l'une des
toutes premières femmes aux commandes
d'un chasseur à son actif 1800 heures de
vol des missions au Tchad et en
Afghanistan
c'est quoi l'esprit pilote dont vous
parliez tout à l'heure c'est l'esprit de
l'aviateur c'est le challenge du défi il
s'agit d'être bon mais il s'agit d'être
le meilleur aussi
en clair c'est la compète Comme dans Top
Gun
[Musique]
des frères pilote de ligne un mari et un
père pilote de chasse Anne-Laure à
l'aviation dans le sang
à 37 ans fini l'émission de guerre elle
s'est reconvertie en instructrice de vol
et à troqué son mirage pour cet avion
école le Cyrus bonjour
voilà le lieutenant et dont on parlait
tout à l'heure c'est une élève en
formation en vol donc moi je suis très
contente parce que c'est la génération
nouvelle qui amène des femmes super mais
ça peut plus approfond l'ambition de cet
élève marcher dans les pas d'Anne-Laure
un rêve particulièrement difficile parmi
les 23000 femmes de l'Armée de l'Air
seul 15 son pilote de chasse
un porte-bonheur non avant de voler non
pas forcément
c'est la meilleure protection
il y en a qui en ont mais comme quoi
c'est souvent les hommes en fait
[Musique]
des petites peluches petits trucs comme
ça je pense après
ce jeune lieutenant a déjà emmagasiné
18h de vol sur Cyrus avant de partir en
mission sur rafale il lui faudra encore
trois années de formation après Salon de
Provence
le Cyrus est un avion moderne ces
instruments sont numériques comme le
Rafale pour habituer les élèves au
chasseurs de dernières génération
Anne-Laure apprend son nouveau métier
elle vient observer le cours très
intéressant c'est la première fois que
je vole avec un élève et du coup je vais
voir comment ça va se passer quand je
vais être moi en place droite à la place
de l'instructeur
[Musique]
70 nœuds c'est la vitesse de décollage
pour les profanes 130 km heure
en quelques minutes l'avion grimpe à
3000 mètres
l'élève fait face à une première
difficulté la radio est saturée c'est
l'aéroport international de Marseille
[Musique]
énormément de trafic qui décolle
qui c'est bien sûr des vidéos les hôtels
se dirige vers la mer et met le cap au
sud un cap mythique chez les aviateurs
sensiblement sud et nous allons aller
durant quelques instants vers
c'était le 31 juillet 1944 c'est par ici
que Saint-Exupéry s'est abîmée en mer
après une heure de vol la piste de
Salon-de-Provence est en vue vitesse
d'approche 150 km heure
et bien posé
quel
le cours est terminé l'élève a fait un
sans faute
qu'est-ce qui vous plaît le plus dans le
fait d'être dans les airs comme ça
[Musique]
c'est vrai que pour moi vraiment voler
c'est je pense que c'est l'un des enfin
je pense que c'est le plus beau mais qui
au monde tout simplement c'est l'un des
plus beaux bureaux alors là on a un open
space carrément au dessus des nuages
tous les jours on voit le soleil donc
autant dire que enfin je pense qu'on est
quand même les seuls à avoir cette neige
c'est gris il fait pas beau il fait
froid le sol au sol on monte dans la
viande on dépasse la couche nuageuse et
on se retrouve toute liberté
[Musique]
voir l'élève aux commandes de son cirrus
m'a donné envie d'essayer moi aussi
alors nous propose un cours de vol mais
en toute sécurité celui-là et je vais
être sa toute première élève
on peut décoller
on dirait un vrai cockpit d'avion un
magnifique jeu vidéo à 100000 €
cette machine s'entraîne les futurs
pilotes à l'école de l'air ils devront
cumuler au moins 12 heures de simulateur
en l'air encore le cours commence
3 2 1 c'est parti voilà on est parti
alors
vous pouvez ramener le manche vers
l'arrière
plus
encore un peu plus ah d'école de travers
déjà vous vous rendez compte sur votre
ou à gauche et on a décollé ça y est ben
là c'est bien vous tournez on va aller
voir la mer là je tourne on va voir la
mer là je tourne voilà je veux dire STOP
là on a l'autoroute en bas
chaque détail de la région est reproduit
à l'identique ces bluffants on a quand
même l'impression de voler c'est
impressionnant ça donne la même
sensation de tourner voir de vertige il
y a des gens que ça rend malade de voir
le simulateur
pendant que Carole apprend le b.a.ba du
pilotage moi j'ai bien envie de m'amuser
sur le joujou d'à côté j'ai déjà une
petite expérience du manche alors je
vais ici
oser la voltige c'est tout qui vient les
murs
l'avantage du simulateur c'est qu'on
peut tout risquer sans se cracher
maintenant je vais m'offrir un grand
luxe quelque chose que je ne ferai
jamais en vrai un appontage sur le
Charles de Gaulle 200 mètres de piste
c'est très court
à droite un peu plus alors
nickel
bien
arrête de jouer Benjamin moi j'essaye
d'apprendre à piloter
voyez en 3 minutes vous avez compris
complètement comment
ça va
être pilote de chasse
maintenant il ne te reste plus qu'à
atterrir Carole rester comme ça on
descend un tout petit peu plus parce
qu'on est un peu haut
merci
c'est très très bien j'ai une super prof
mais je suis contente parce que vous
êtes ma première élève et vu comme vous
avez bien progressé je pense que j'étais
motivé
avant de devenir instructrice Anne-Laure
a enchaîné les opérations extérieures
partout la France est engagée Afrique
Afghanistan la guerre pour de vrai il
n'y a pas d'image des bruits des
sensations qui vous reviennent
les sonneries les alertes quand une
roquette était détectée comme volant au
dessus de la base où on doit tous se
coucher par terre attendre que ça passe
et prier pour que la roquette tombe pas
à côté de soi comment on appréhende le
fait de de tirer sur des cibles humaines
alors c'est sûr que encore une fois dit
en tant que tel ça fait un peu boucher
mais bon je l'ai pris comme
la seule manière de défendre des
personnes qui se faisaient elles-mêmes
tirer dessus des alliés en l'occurrence
des militaires américains qui se
faisaient tirer dessus
qui des talibans qui posaient des
IED des bombes au sol on se dit on est
là pour les arrêter finalement et je
pense que dans ce cadre là on se pose
pas trop de questions on y repense pas
après honnêtement je me suis jamais dit
j'aurais pas dû le faire
un sacré métier
[Musique]
sans compter qu'à de l'or et jeune maman
et que son mari est pilote de chasse lui
aussi une famille hors du commun qui
nous invite chez elle à l'heure du thé
alors et Anthony vivent dans un village
à quelques kilomètres de la base
Anthon
ils se sont mariés il y a trois ans un
ménage de pilote de chasse c'est rare il
n'y en a que trois ou quatre dans toute
la France
c'est pas très romantique
on passe plus de temps à se coucher par
terre pour éviter les tirs de roquette
que à faire des dîners en amoureux mais
bon en tout cas c'était une ambiance de
travail on a vu qu'on travaillait de la
même façon qu'on s'entendait bien dans
le dans le travail qu'on avait un peu
les mêmes passions pour le sport etc la
montagne
et entre les missions ils sont devenus
parents un petit garçon de 2 ans et un
autre de trois mois sont venus agrandir
la famille
[Musique]
est-ce que devenir maman et vous devenir
papa ça a changé votre rapport au danger
ça reste un métier de passion donc
bon on aurait tendance un petit peu non
pas oublier mais voilà un peu la phase
en disant non bon les enfants finalement
ils ont pâtissent pas tant que ça et
après quand la réalité nous rattrape au
galop quand il y a des accidents quand
il y a des décès de proches c'est sûr
que là on y pense on y pense on se pose
la question et quand on rentre le soir
le petit bisou aux enfants il prend une
toute autre une toute autre teneur quoi
donc
une question quand un militaire rentre
d'opération c'est alors comment ça s'est
passé avec les enfants comment ont-ils
réagi surtout des petits en bas âge il
nous reconnaissent pas forcément tout de
suite
Anne-Laure n'aura plus ce problème
pourrait l'émission de guerre
on n'a pas encore fini avec les
opérations extérieures
[Musique]
c'est notre dernier jour à l'école de
l'air j'ai enquillé les épreuves de
lutte de survie et d'éjections j'ai
enfin droit à ma récompense un petit
tour en avion de chasse je suis avec
Sébastien tu sais Carole ton élève de
planeur il m'accompagne à la base
d'orange
c'est sur cette machine que je volerais
aujourd'hui un Mirage 2000 il y en a 24
stationnés ici
moi je préfère
car un vol en avion de chasse peut-être
rude et il faut mettre une tenue
spéciale la combinaison antigène
lors de grosses accélérations ces
pantalons gonflent et compriment les
jambes comme ça le sang continue de
diriger le cerveau il ne part pas dans
les jambes et le pilote ne perd pas
connaissance
le mirage de villea
donc voilà je te le présente
bonjour
la mission de ces mirages c'est la
protection du territoire en cas de
menace aérienne Ross a moins de 15
minutes pour intercepter sa cible
décollage compris
aujourd'hui je participe à son vol
d'entraînement un exercice de routine
[Musique]
justement
la cible peut être un appareil en
détresse ou un avion hostile ses pilotes
doivent empêcher un 11 septembre sur le
sol français ils appellent ça la police
de l'air
dans un mirage de nuit qui va lui en
savoir toutes les couleurs
et moi je pense que le pilote va
s'amuser un peu avec lui enfin j'espère
désolé
sur terre comme sur mer et bolide
j'adore ça dans les airs il ne manquait
que la viande chasse
cette fois ça y est je vais goûter au
joujou ultime un avion à plusieurs
dizaines de millions d'euros enfin
joujou façon de parler
et au pire du pire c'est Jacques
si la panne est trop importante et qu'on
doit quitter l'avion je te dirai trois
fois injection
tu penses immédiatement à prendre ta
position donc tu chopes la poignée à
demain et tu tires
si tu veux je me sens prêt dans sécurité
qu'un pilote de chasse globalement
l'accélération est impressionnante en
quelques secondes nous sommes à plus de
300 km heure
et très vite les premières sensations
arrivent
c'est ça une machine volante qui peut
dépasser les 2000 km/h Paris - Marseille
en moins de 20 minutes
le plus éprouvant pour le corps ce n'est
pas la vitesse ce sont les virages
voilà ça c'est
une accélération de 2g en clair mon
corps fait deux fois son poids je me
sens littéralement écrasé sur mon siège
je comprends mieux l'intérêt de ma
combinaison anti g voilà
[Applaudissements]
un objet un pilote pèse environ 700 kg
moi je ne pourrais pas supporter un
téléphone très vite je tomberai dans les
vapes on appelle ça le voile noir
mais Rose pompilote n'en a pas encore
fini avec moi
une petite barrique toutes les légères
[Applaudissements]
un tour complet sur soi-même
[Musique]
bonjour les dégâts
selon le radar l'hélicoptère que nous
devons intercepter et proches mais au
mieux du ciel on a bien du mal à le
repérer et juste devant pourtant
il est beaucoup plus lent que nous en un
clin d'oeil nous l'avons rattrapé nous
entrons en contact radio avec lui nous
devons vite comprendre ces intentions si
il est perdu nous devons le guider à bon
port s'il est hostiles nous pourrions la
battre évidemment en dernier recours
là pas de menace une fois l'hélicoptère
identifié nous pouvons rentrer à la base
et heureusement parce que je suis
lessivé
[Musique]
mon vol a duré presque une heure et
demie
[Musique]
voilà c'était comment
c'était très très bien mais il fallait
pas que ça dure beaucoup plus longtemps
[Musique]
très peu de temps en très peu de temps
faut beaucoup voler pour apprécier quoi
tu as le stress et voilà quoi c'était
moi quoi
bon on n'a pas passé le mur du son mais
maintenant je sais ce que c'est que
voler sur un avion de chasse
moi je suis dans une toute autre
ambiance bien plus solennelle l'école de
l'air est né en 1933 c'est une véritable
institution avec ses symboles et ses
devises aujourd'hui le général me fait
entrer dans le sein des saints et donc
on va aller dans la salle des mains et
dans cette salle de marbre on nous revêt
ce magnifique symbole de l'officier on
voit ici voilà ce symbole de l'officier
chaque nouvelle promotion reçoit le
poignard de l'officier c'est une
cérémonie d'un autre temps les élèves
sont adoubés comme des chevaliers
et réfléchissent sur l'engagement qui
prenne sur le serment qui font vis-à-vis
voilà vis-à-vis de la République
vis-à-vis de nos valeurs on s'engage
toute une vie à défendre
tous les Français
nous entrons maintenant dans la salle
d'honneur un sanctuaire auquel très peu
de civils peuvent accéder
le paradoxe technologie et puis en même
temps valeur très ancienne très humaine
c'est ce qui crée le c'est ce qui crée
le l'attrait de cet univers et
finalement les jeunes ils sont très
attachés contrairement à ce qu'on
pourrait imaginer le monde est très
instable on a besoin quelque part
d'avoir ce point d'ancrage le point
d'ancrage est ici on peut pas
imaginer autre lieu pour le point
d'ancrage tous les aviateurs connaissent
cet endroit et c'est ici que c'est ici
que les paradoxes s'estompent ici se
forge l'identité de chaque nouvelle
aviateur
tous viennent s'inspirer des anciens
pilotes disparus de leur histoire et de
leur valeur
comme dans un temple je suis entouré de
reliques
le registre de vol de Saint-Exupéry est
ouvert au jour de sa disparition
c'est notre dernier soir à l'école et
pour finir en beauté notre immersion
Sébastien et ses camarades nous ont
organisé une petite fête d'adieu
bonsoir
ça c'est la salle de cohésion le foyer
quoi les élèves pas si leur temps libre
c'est de la part des élèves de l'école
voilà
merci beaucoup mais qu'est-ce que ça
peut être
un châle de fils de l'air
c'est un carré regardez-moi ça faire
face merci beaucoup
il y a une chose qui nous tient
énormément à coeur cette citation là
donc ce que je vous propose c'est que
vous mémorisiez ça pour nous maintenant
et que vous nous la récitiez pour
pouvoir mériter cette combinaison
ça va pas être évident
le Capitaine Guynemer c'est le héros de
l'armée de l'air française il est mort
pendant la Première Guerre mondiale
après avoir abattu 53 appareils et demi
il avait 22 ans
Carole je vais avoir besoin de ton aide
le 11 septembre
après 3 ans de combat
tre
le 11 septembre 1917
[Applaudissements]
j'ai bien mérité ma combinaison c'est
trop la classe beau comme un aviateur
ce que je n'avais pas prévu c'est qu'ici
je serai toujours un bisou
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
même le général a fait le déplacement ça
nous fera une belle photo de famille
notre immersion à l'école de l'air
s'achève d'autres univers d'autres vies
nous attendent
[Musique]